let's play a little baseball let's hope
the rain stays away it's been good for
the red sox the last couple of games but
uh
we'd prefer to stay away hopefully that
will be the case
we're about set to get started here at
fenway with the marlins in town for game
two of the series it's native aldi
in his 11th start of the season one and
one on starling marty
one one is pulled into left by martay
and it gets all the way to the monster
verdugo gets to it quickly his throw is
offline
and it's a double for starling martay so
he's a board here for the three-hitter
for the marlins
jesus aguilar marte at second
one down first inning the pitch is cut
out and missed
and of all these strikes out aguilar
that was a nasty curveball right there
by a baldi
that had some snap to it look at this
break go up to third base
goes martay garrett cooper the hitter
he's d.h today
2-2 pitch fastball strike three called
on the outside corner beautiful
pitch by avaldi he has two strikeouts
for the marlins today it's trevor rogers
of course this
top three in the marlins rotation has
been fantastic all year long with sandy
alcatra pablo lopez
and trevor rogerson statistically
speaking you can make a case that trevor
has been the best of the bunch
that was his answer reason i ask it
high fly ball to right long run sierra
and able to put that one away marlon's
had a crack top of the sixth and then
the reigns came
soft line drive and diaz makes the play
two down they're trying to get your
attention
jd martinez out to center marte is there
well no nerves in the first a one
two three inning for trevor rogers then
baldi going back to work here in a
scoreless top of the second and starts
corey dickerson who had a couple of hits
yesterday
and dickerson strikes out on 97 and
that's three straight
k's for nate of aldi yeah dickerson he
has problems against the vault he's now
open ten in his career
so what a way for evaldi and it brings
up john bertie
it's another strikeout for avaldi and
that is four in a row out of the gates
yeah that's the cutter right there from
the baldy to pick up the strikeout
i'm only trying to strike out the side
here in the second
is one two got him swinging
five straight k's for baldi and the
pitch to rafael devers
here's his 1-2 devers rolls it right
side
aguilar on the backhand to the covering
rogers endeavors beats it out
good hustle down the line and the second
baseman diaz is over on the left side of
the infield
renfro hits it hard past devers in the
left
a two-strike hit for him and it's
back-to-back singles for the sox in the
second so the red sox with a couple of
men on him one out
dull back over his last 11 his last four
he hits this one hard past the dive of
diaz
debors rounds third as dickerson throws
up the line
and the red sox strike first so dalbeck
picks up his 22nd rbi of the season
and now christian arroyo gets an
opportunity with two on and two out for
the red sox
first pitch he sees ground ball through
the left side and the base hit
renfro rounds third dickerson comes up
throwing here's the throw to the plate a
tag at the plate and they
got him we'll see renfro immediately
gets up
it was a good strong throw from corey
dickerson
chad fairchild called him out at home
here's another look jp did they get him
i think he got him on the back right
shoulder renfro was saying no
they're going to wave it off the inning
is over
and they cut down renfro at home
of aldi z02 and he strikes out jose
debors and that's a half dozen k's
already for nate of aldi
two on two out the three two runners
take off it's pulled the third
right at devers and the baldi gets out
of end the top of the third
pulled the left field and down for a hit
and rolling toward the wall
jd martinez has a double here with two
outs in the third
an extra base hit number 200 for jd
martinez with the red sox after he got
to
300 rbis yesterday one man down
brings it up hunter renfro this is
grounded fair down the line by
renfro oh he is scorching right now
all the way into the corner and it's the
second hit of the ball game for hunter
renfrow
here's the wiki who struck out so two
out runner's still at second
he goes the opposite way into right
field here
scoring renfro from second and the red
sox add on in the fourth
rbi single for plawiki as he poked that
one
between the first baseman and the second
baseman into right field
wiki driving in his third run of the
season two-nothing boston
josh taylor the red sox bullpen as we
hit that 90 pitch limit
or mark i should say for a baldi another
one two
and he strikes out sierra
lewecky completes it strikeout number
seven two down
now that was a splitter right there
that's the best one he's thrown all day
that had some action on it
and here comes josh taylor who's had 11
straight scoreless appearances
and the marlins have the tying runs on
base so here's john bertie right-handed
hitters
1-2 and taylor got him swinging
second out of the inning and here comes
issan diaz who has been struggling
one two pulled in the air to right
renfro circles and back pedals
to make the catch and the marlins strand
two
and now they have the tying run in
scoring position runners at second and
third abino in for the second
consecutive game
inside ball four and they will be loaded
for jesus aguilar aveeno's payoff pitch
he got him swinging two down now he
stayed with his best pitch in his best
pitch as the fighter
and picked up the huge strikeout and
there's the result of not a happy hitter
taylor loves it the cleanup man garrett
cooper now with two out
of he knows one two he got him swinging
oh what a punch out for avino endeavors
to face simber
he goes the opposite way here sending
dickerson
back and it's off the wall
deborah sprinting to second and diving
in with a double
the red sox have a man in scoring
position they'd love another run here is
when a renfro comes up opposite way
past aguilar in the right sierra comes
up throwing
divers in safely to add on and renfro to
second
it's a three-nothing red sox lead so
here's matt barnes now in a safe
situation with a three-nothing lead
jesus aguilar will bat the marlins need
one more man on
and a line drive base hit center field
sierra rounding third he'll score
marlins are on the board and the tying
rental come to the plate after the rbi
single from jesus aguilar
cooper tying run has reached home plate
this is grounded towards second arroyo
flips to bogart it's on the first
and that's a red sox winner barnes
buttons it up and the red sox win 3-1